you may have heard about people in the
tech field and their companies using
proxies but what even are proxies what
are they used for and so you get one
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies a proxy server
is a gateway between you and Internet it
is an intermediary server that separates
the end-user from the websites to view
proxy servers provide varying levels of
security privacy and protection based on
your use case and needs when you are
using a proxy server internet traffic
flows through the proxy server to the
address that you requested then the
request flows back through the pocke
server and a proxy server forwards to
receive information onto you so how
exactly do proxy servers work so as you
guys already know any computer or device
connect to the Internet has its own
unique IP address a proxy server is
basically a computer on internet with
its own unique IP address when you send
a web request the proxy server sends a
request on your behalf and affords the
receive data onto you there are four
main types of proxy servers starting
with transparent proxies a transparent
proxy tells a website that is a proxy
and pass along your IP address
businesses public libraries and schools
often use transparent proxies in order
to do content filtering the next type of
proxy is an anonymous proxy this
possible web said that it is a proxy but
above pass on your IP address this can
help prevent identity theft and make
your browsing history private and
distorting proxies very similar to an
anonymous proxy a distorted proxy sends
along a fake IP address but still
identifies itself as a proxy since this
process ends on false IP address you can
get access to blocked geographic content
just like a VPN finally a high anonymity
proxy server will periodically change
the IP address that it gives a website
this makes a very difficult to track
which traffic belongs to who high
anonymity proxy servers like tor are one
of the most secure and private ways to
browse the Internet there are two types
of proxy servers with HTTP for service
being older of the two
HTTP proxies are designed for web-based
traffic and make all your traffic flow
through the remote proxy Sox proxies on
the other hand simply pass on any
traffic that it gets the downside to Sox
proxies is that there are slower than
HTTP proxies one thing to keep in mind
is that neither one supports encryption
all right but what would you even use a
proxy for in the first place
well it comes out to five different
reasons to control internet usage of
employees or children better savings and
improved speeds improve security privacy
benefits and access to blocked content
so what is the difference between proxy
and a VPN well much like a proxy server
a VPN also makes your traffic look like
it is coming from a different IP address
however a VPN connection captures all of
the network data that come from the
device that it is configured on for
example proxy servers simply act as a
middleman when you're being web sites or
other applications such as BitTorrent
repeats on the other hand include
everything from online games and even
Windows updates running in the
background furthermore that entire
process is passed through a heavily
encrypted tunnel
this makes VPNs ideal for any type of
high-stakes network use that require
security and privacy however repeaters
do have their own set of disadvantages
to get a good VPN you pretty much have
to pay also ap a good amount of
computing power as well so if you're
just casually browsing website and would
like to get some more privacy and
security or just get access to blocked
content and a proxy server may be right
for you but that's just what I think
what do you guys think do you guys have
a proxy server or a VPN and if so which
one do you think is better make sure
comment that down below also if you guys
liked this video and that was helpful
for the next couple like and consider
subscribing if you'd like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]